die gefahren aus dem all sind real und
wir haben nichts wirklich nichts um uns
zu verteidigen
riesige asteroiden könnten bei einer
kollision mit der erde das gesamte leben
auf unserem planeten auslöschen
doch schon bald startet der erste tests
an der planetaren verteidigungs mission
denn es geht um eine ja schier
unglaubliche zahl von objekten die auf
der erde schon in den nächsten 100
jahren einschlagen könnten und die haben
mich persönlich dann doch ziemlich
beeindruckt klicks und switches dreimal
pro woche spannende science ihres
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen und ja das
ist das buch zu klicks zum science in
future mein ganzer stolz per aufzug in
den weltraum da geht es um die zukunft
und darum dass sie ganz anders ist als
viele denken denn zum beispiel einen
aufzug in den weltraum können wir heute
schon bauen das kommt jetzt bald heraus
das buch und die buchpremiere ist hier
in berlin in einem später also einem
kiosk schon nächste woche am 13 oktober
jeder und jede die oder der vorbeikommt
und ein buch dabei hat oder sich vor ort
zulegt wir haben genug da bekommt von
mir ein freigetränk um mit mir darauf
anzustoßen und natürlich auch eine
persönliche widmung um 20 uhr geht es
los und also hier findet ihr alle infos
oder in der video beschreibung und
natürlich findet das unter strengen und
sicheren corona auflagen statt
tatsächlich ist es nicht die frage ob
ein gigantischer passiert irgendwann mit
der erde kollidieren wird sondern wann
die zeit spielt also gegen uns davon
geht auch tesla und space ex chef elon
musk aus er hatte im vergangenen sommer
2009 10 zum asteroiden apophis
getwittert der der erde bedenklich nahe
kommen wird großartiger name über diesen
würde ich mir keine sorgen machen aber
irgendwann wird ein großer felsen die
erde treffen und wir haben derzeit keine
verteidigung ab profis wird die erde in
neun jahren also 2029 um nur knapp
30.000 kilometer verfehlen und das ist
in astronomischen dimensionen wirklich
sehr sehr sehr wenig damit wird er der
erde sogar näher sein als die meisten
wetter und kommunikationssatelliten die
etwa in 36.000 kilometern geostationäre
über uns schweben
kommt uns dann so nach dass wegen sogar
mit bloßem auge erkennen können dabei
legte er fast 40.000 kilometer pro
stunde zurück sieben jahre später also
im jahr 2036 wird sich der gigantische
assoziiert dann wohl erneut annähernd
falls es zur kursänderung kommt und
apophis doch auf der erde einschlagen
sollte was niemand erwartet würde dies
eine explosion von 900 megatonnen tnt
entsprechen
der vergleich mit der zeitbombe macht
die ausmaße deutlich diese größte
nukleare explosion die durch menschen
verursacht wurde entsprach 50 megatonnen
tnt apophis würde also mit knapp der
zwanzigfachen wucht einschlagen das
fatale dabei selbst wenn wir jetzt
sicher wüssten dass sich apophis oder
aber ein anderes objekt auf gezieltem
kollisionskurs mit der erde befände
hätten wir kaum eine chance dieses
tödliche ereignis abzuwenden denn obwohl
forschungsteams weltweit mit hochdruck
an möglichen abwehrstrategien arbeiten
sind diese noch alles andere als
ausgereift die europäische
raumfahrtbehörde esa wie das jetzt
gemeinsam mit der nasa ändern das ziel
des äusserst spektakulären experiments
eine technik zu entwickeln mit der sich
solche gesteinsbrocken umlenken lassen
falls eine kollision mit der erde droht
die nasa ist mit der sonde dort am start
das steht für double sdv direct test
diese soll dann einschlagen und zwar auf
dem erdnahen asteroiden 65 80 3
aufgespürt wurde dieser vor 24 jahren
oder 96 und astronomie teams weltweit
checkten damals ziemlich schnell dass es
sich bei diesem objekt um einen doppel
körper handelt deswegen sein name rudi
muss denn das ist die griechische
bezeichnung für zwilling der größere
brocken von beiden hat einen durchmesser
von 780 m
der kleinere einen durchmesser von etwa
160 metern
der mond wird manchmal auch als diddy
moon oder die more fonds bezeichnet
bisher wissen wir dass die mossos den
größeren körper in einer entfernung von
1,1 kilometern umkreist und für eine
umrundung rund 11,9 stunden benötigt und
um das direkt einmal klarzustellen das
zielobjekt ist aktuell keine bedrohung
für unsere erde
das nasa manöver dient lediglich dazu
und für den ernstfall vorzubereiten das
geht hier auch weitaus risikoärmer als
beim objekt
auf kollisionskurs wäre denn wenn hier
etwas schief geht dann kommt uns dieses
objekt trotzdem nicht mehr und es
besteht keine gefahr einer kollision bei
dem experiment im fokus der kleinere der
beiden brocken denn hier möchte die nasa
ihre raum seine dateien schlagen lassen
und so seine bahn verändern konkret
sieht der plan so aus mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 23.000 kilometern
pro stunde soldat auf die mossos treffen
so soll ein impuls auf den himmelskörper
übertragen werden so dass nicht nur
seine geschwindigkeit sondern auch seine
bahn leicht verändert wird durch den
aufprall wird material von der
oberfläche aus gesteuert dadurch soll es
einen zusätzlichen impuls geben wodurch
dieser effekt verstärkt wird bisherigen
berechnungen zufolge könnte es zur
veränderung der bahn geschwindigkeit von
etwa 0,4 mm pro sekunde kommen klingt
zunächst nach einer minimalen
veränderung doch fachleuten zufolge wäre
eine solche neuausrichtung groß genug um
sie mit teleskopen von der erde aus zu
messen dieses manöver würde uns damit
endlich zeigen ob wir mit solch einer
mission tatsächlich auch einen
asteroiden der sich auf kollisionskurs
mit der erde befände erfolgreich
umlenken können denn fest steht schon
eine kleine flugbahn änderung eines
asteroiden wenn sie weit genug weg
erfolg könnte das fortbestehen der erde
sicherstellen sogar für die fachleute
ist dieses experiment ganz besonders
spannend und spektakulär denn es handelt
sich um den ersten himmelskörper dessen
physikalische und orbitale eigenschaften
von menschenhand verändert werden
die hera sonde wird von dem
satellitenbauer ohb systems ag in bremen
gebaut und bekommt dafür von der esa
etwa 130 millionen euro
der chef des unternehmens marco fuchs
sagt die gefahren aus dem all sind real
dort gibt es millionen von
gesteinsbrocken dem falle einer
kollision das leben auf der erde
auslöschen können hera soll im oktober
2004 und 20 staaten und weitere zwei
jahre später also zeit dass ein 26 das
ziel die die moz erreichen
auch die steuerung der hera sonde soll
von deutschland aus erfolgen konkret
nämlich vom esa kontrollzentrum esoc in
darmstadt mit hilfe von hera soll dann
genauer untersucht werden welche effekte
der aufprall auf die more france hat die
sonde an sich ist nach esa angaben etwa
so groß wie ein schreibtisch der
offizielle plan sieht vor dass die sonne
sechs monate lang daten sammeln soll
mit an bord wird her
für nicht nur kameras und
wissenschaftliche instrumente haben
sondern auch würfelförmige
mini-satelliten diese beiden klubs setzt
sollen den asteroiden aus nächster nähe
vermessen die forschenden wollen damit
nicht nur die zusammensetzung und
struktur des asteroiden genauer
untersuchen sondern auch den
einschlagskrater doch damit nicht genug
die esa hat das ziel mit hilfe von hera
auch weitere technologien auszuprobieren
und zu demonstrieren beispielsweise die
autonome navigation um den asteoriden
herum von den knapp 130 millionen budget
wird deutschland etwa die hälfte
beisteuern doch es handelt sich auch um
etwas wirklich besonderes um eine
planetare verteidigungs mission mitte
september 2020 also haben die esa und
die olb die verträge für das projekt ära
unterschrieben damit hat die europäische
raumfahrtbehörde esa den startschuss für
ihre erste mission zu asteroiden abwehr
gegeben dazu der esa- direktor rolf
densing wenn der test erfolgreich ist
sollten wir uns bereit machen für
wirkliche ablenkungsmanöver wir wollen
die menschheit schützen vor allem die
autonomie die die sonne in dieser großen
entfernung haben muss bezeichnet er als
große herausforderung her ist teil des
sogenannten aida projekts das steht für
sj impact andy fleckchen assessment hier
aber die europäische und amerikanische
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
gemeinsam im bereich der planetaren
verteidigung das wird auch höchste zeit
denn fachleute waren immer wieder vor
der bedrohung aus dem all und plädieren
für eine weltweite zusammenarbeit und
den aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystems maßgeblich an der
entwicklung und erforschung dieser
themen beteiligt ist die nasa behörde
namens planetary die fans team noch im
sommer 2018 hatte die nasa ein
ausführliches strategiepapier zu
asteroiden abwehr vorgelegt demnach
müssen dringend möglichkeiten entwickelt
werden mit denen die flugbahn von
gesteinsbrocken beeinflusst werden
können wichtig sind also vor allem zwei
sachen erstens potenziell gefährliche
asteroiden müssen früh genug aufgespürt
werden
doch da liegt die erste große
herausforderung denn das klappt noch
lange nicht immer so flog beispielsweise
der hast du in 2009/10 okay im juli des
vergangenen jahres 2019 unbemerkt an der
erde vorbei fachleuten zufolge war der
fast aus dem nichts gekommen und dennoch
ist in einer distanz von nur 72 1199
kilometern an der erde vorbeigerast und
das mit einem durchmesser von gut
sich metern rund einen kilometer groß
dagegen ist der weltraum felsbrocken
2020 q6 diesen hatte einen
brasilianische astronom erst anfang
september 2020 entdeckt 90 prozent der
erdnahe objekte mit solch einer größe
gelten eigentlich als bekannt doch die
meisten hat zu jedem beobachtungs
missionen sind auf der nordhalbkugel
stationiert deswegen war 2020 q6 der
sich von der südlichen hemisphäre
genähert hatte zunächst unentdeckt
geblieben am 10 september hatte er dann
die erde in einem großen abstand von 40
millionen kilometer passiert also mehr
als die zehnfache distanz von der erde
zum mond dennoch schrieb die planetary
zurzeit die danach dass diese späte
entdeckung deutlich mache dass mehr für
den schutz unseres planeten getan werden
muss laut der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa ist es ein absolut
riesige anzahl von objekten den nächsten
100 jahren möglicherweise die erde
treffen könnten es sind nämlich derzeit
870 das ist schon eine ziemlich
beeindruckende zahl und das sind nur die
objekte von denen wir wissen dazu stefan
ohl am eck vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt in einem interview
mit golem.de die frage ist überhaupt
nicht ob wir wieder getroffen werden die
frage ist wann wir wieder getroffen
werden
doch das aufspüren wenn es denn gelingt
ist nur der erste entscheidende schritt
in einem zweiten schritt muss es auch
darum gehen aktiv zu werden und
strategien zur planeten verteidigung
einsetzen zu können fachleute sind der
ansicht dass bei asteroiden ab einer
größe von 50 metern über eine ablenkung
nachgedacht werden muss und genau dazu
könnte uns die daten mission gemeinsam
mit er wertvolle erkenntnisse liefern
denn es handelt sich um nichts weniger
als die erste planetare verteidigungs
mission überhaupt übrigens haben in der
vergangenheit auch weitaus kleinere
brocken große schäden auf der erde
angerichtet ein beispiel dafür musste
die russische millionenstadt
tscheljabinsk vor sieben jahren erleben
damals war dieser aspekt gerade einmal
20 meter groß dennoch wurden bei der
druckwelle rund 1500 menschen verletzt
und zahlreiche gebäude beschädigt solche
kleinen felsen können also bei einem
anschlag nördlich gewaltige schäden
anrichten und achtung die gefährdung
steigt mit der größe exponentiell weil
das volumen der kugel sogar nicht nur
zum quadrat sondern sogar hoch
mai steigt das volumen einer kugel wird
mit 4,3 mal pi mal radius hoch drei
berechnet also wer lust hat kann das ja
für verschiedene radien berechnen 5 und
25 meter das entspricht zu einem
maximalen brocken von 50 metern
durchmesser also wie viel mal größer ist
das volumen wenn der radius fünf mal
größer ist da kommen schon ziemlich
beeindruckenden zahlen raus und vor
allem eine sehr beeindruckende
steigerung und je kleiner ein objekt ist
desto größer ist der brems und erhitzung
effekt unserer atmosphäre kleinere
meteore schaffen es meistens nicht mal
bis zum erdboden sie verglühen als
sternschnuppen in unserer atmosphäre für
einen großzügigen spielt die atmosphäre
allerdings so gut wie keine rolle mehr
ja wer ist übrigens überhaupt nicht
aushalten kann natürlich gibt es das
buch auch bei amazon der link ist hier
einfach draufklicken aber ich freue mich
natürlich über jede und jeden die oder
der den lokalen buchhandel unterstützt
und das buch dort kauft also in diesem
sinne bis dann bleibt dran